-Congratulations on a sixth
season of "The Blacklist."
-Thank you.
-It's amazing.
-You've got Glenda Jackson
here tonight.
-How exciting is that?
I mean, I'm very excited
you're here, don't get me wrong.
-Yeah.
-But Glenda Jackson, yeah.
I'm glad.
-Because I want to see -- is she
going to talk about "King Lear"?
-Yes, she's playing King Lear.
-I know, I can't wait to see it.
-You'll go see it, though?
-Yeah, of course.
I saw her in "Three Tall Women."
-"Three Tall Women" was amazing.
Do you go to a lot
of Broadway shows?
-You know, I try.
I mean, things are busy.
-Yeah. You're so busy,
do you have time to even
watch the news?
Can you even do that?
-I don't watch the news.
-Yeah.
-I don't watch the news at all.
I read the news.
And, you know,
I read it every day.
-It comes out every day.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But I -- I don't know,
I read a lot of news.
You know, I don't know.
It goes in cycles for me.
I'm having a terrible conundrum
now of how to process the news.
-Yeah.
-Today.
-I don't think you're alone.
A lot of --
-Right. And so, you know, so I
sometimes -- but I vacillate,
like, in all things in my life,
I have never figured out
moderation
in any way, shape, or form.
And it's that way with the news
as well,
where it's either for me
just consuming a ton of it
and trying to figure out
a way to, you know,
put it together and process it
and get rid of it.
And then that, or sometimes it
just has to be a blackout.
I'll skip the first section
of the paper,
I'll go right to, you know,
the later sections.
-Do you feel better
on those days?
-In some ways.
-Yeah.
-I think that the certain things
in the news are being --
we're seeing too much of it.
Especially --
Sometimes I succumb to the
24-hour news cycle.
-Yeah.
-Which, I'm very envious of you.
Because I was thinking about
this tonight.
You know, I was actually talking
to the producer backstage
about the fact that you're
forced to process it.
I mean, you really --
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-And in a way,
it's tremendously digestive.
-Oh, yeah.
-You can consume it,
you can metabolize it,
and then you can [bleep] it out.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what I mean?
And get rid of it.
-Yeah. And I get to [bleep] it
out in front of an audience.
-Right, right, right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fantastic. Anyway...
-I want to talk about
simpler times.
Because one of my favorite
things about when you
come on the show
is you have wonderful stories
about growing up.
And I want to ask,
you took a lot of family trips
with your family,
as you do with family trips.
And I -- because I'm excited
about traveling with my kids.
Your family went to Europe.
You would drive around
in a VW, what, van?
-Van. Yeah.
-How is that?
-VW bus.
-A VW bus. That's so Bohemian.
-The Vanagon was the first
VW van.
And we didn't have a Vanagon.
I wanted a Vanagon.
It just felt great.
There was a popup thing.
-Yeah.
-There was, you know,
anything that had a fridge in it
seemed great.
But, you know, I...
yes, the VW bus
was our transport.
My parents were teachers, and we
didn't really have much money.
You know, they didn't
earn very much money.
But what we did have
is every seven years,
they got a sabbatical,
which means that you get
a paid vacation, basically.
And they went to Europe
because we have cousins,
Italian cousins, and so
we'd go over to --
For the two sabbaticals
when I was growing up,
that there were, we went over
to Europe both times.
And both times we picked up a --
we got a van --
a Volkswagen bus,
and we drove around Europe,
and then the Volkswagen bus
became our car
back in the States.
-It was such a hit that
you got one in the states?
-No, no, that car
became -- that bus
became our car
in the United States both times.
-You brought it back?
-It was a trip to Europe,
and the car buying --
you know, we drove around --
-You went to Europe to buy
your car?
-To drive around Europe.
-Yeah, no,
I understand that part.
That's the normal part.
[ Laughter ]
-And then it would
come back with us.
-That's not the normal part.
-Then it would
come back with us.
-Gotcha.
-And it was great
because for me, these are
the --
this was in the days
sort of before seat belts.
I mean, the '50s. I wasn't born
when the seat belts started.
But it was before --
It was still when you're
ignoring seat belts.
-Gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
They had them, but nobody
thought they mattered.
-Yeah. They were something
that you sort of like --
You're sitting on something,
you want to get rid of it.
But I never experienced
a seat belt, really,
because my domain was
the wayback.
You know the wayback?
The wayback. That's what I had.
-Okay.
-Which, I think
that's changed now.
-Okay, the wayback,
meaning just the way back
of the van?
-Yeah, it's where the suitcases
and kids go.
-Okay, gotcha.
-And you're just like --
And at that point, because you
didn't have to be seated,
belted into anything.
There weren't seats.
The wayback was just a space
for luggage, you know?
And you would go back in there.
-So you would just sit
amongst the luggage?
-Yeah, I'd be -- if you're in
the wayback, you take a pillow.
-Yeah.
-You know, so you'd have
a pillow back there.
And a bunch of suitcases
up -- and you know,
it's, like, a space
a little bit smaller than this.
-Yeah.
-So, you know,
you're sort of, like...
-Yeah.
-You got a pillow.
That doesn't look that bad.
-You know, I mean, it's
fantastic when you're a kid.
-Yeah.
-So that couch is
the same sort of ratio --
-I feel like you're trying
to sell me a van right now.
[ Laughter ]
-I am.
Vans are a great fantasy.
I could have lived
in the wayback.
Yes.
Anyway, that was --
and also that became the last VW
bus that we drove around Europe
and then came back and brought
it back with us.
That became my first car.
-Really?
-Yeah. And it was fantastic
because I went to this school
in Massachusetts.
It was a big, huge, sort of
college-sized boarding school,
but I was a day student.
I lived in the next town over.
And I had a Volkswagen bus.
It was crazy, you know?
-I mean, you were like
the towny kid with a bus?
-With a bus, yeah.
-I mean, you must have been
the coolest kid at that school.
-Well...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
We'll talk about that next time.
James Spader, everybody!